disturbing video capturing the crisis at
our southern border
as a little migrant boy found sobbing
and wandering alone after being
abandoned in the texas desert watch
huh
sadly that young boy is just one of more
than 19 000 unaccompanied migrant
children that are in federal custody
right now
and fox news just learning that border
patrol has arrested an ms-13 gang member
caught trying to sneak into the u.s
these developments leaving many to ask
where has the vice president been who
was supposed to
handle this crisis kamala harris taking
heat for traveling all across the
country but still not going down to the
southern border
the vp making stops on both coasts and
to the city of chicago over the past two
weeks
but the white house says she has no
plans to visit the border harris did
speak
on the phone today to mexico's president
pete let me start with you
you know if you have a policy that says
don't come now but if you do come we
will not send the children back
then the children are going to keep
coming of course and the people
invested in the ability to send children
as their golden ticket to america
will keep exploiting the children
separating
kids from their parents which was i
believe the last the big grievance from
the last administration
the only thing worse than uh then bad
leadership is no leadership no one's
responsible for what's happening at the
border
because it's a crisis they created the
by administration that they're they're
ignoring
they will deny and allow to fester
because it's not a priority
it's a shiny object over there right now
dana but they've got coveted relief and
infrastructure on the mind they've got
hr1 on the mind until it's politically
advantageous
dana that's the thing because they'll
never let a good crisis
go to waste so ultimately once it whips
around a few months from now when the
numbers dip and they say now it's time
to deal with this
travesty that was somehow donald trump's
fault we're gonna do dreamer 3.0 and
dreamer 4.0 and these 19 000 kids that
are then 30 40 50 000 because of their
policies
now have to be legalized it's a problem
they created they will solve for their
own political gain and that's the
travesty this whole thing and kids like
that
are the visual image that should jar
each of us
greg as i tried to figure out a way to
stretch the definition of infrastructure
maybe the republicans should start
calling these migrant children
infrastructure and get some attention
yeah you know
or i wouldn't be surprised that they
didn't say like oh no he's crying tears
of joy
because he's in the united states where
there's the lovable president biden
and by the way i love how they're
they're considering
uh filling a gap you know to to reduce
the influx yes
and that is um apparently not building a
wall
even though a wall essentially fills a
gap but this is
everything that that activists and the
democrats love to do is that
they like to play with the terminology
so kids in cages are just in temporary
comfort suites
uh the msn gang member dana is actually
an asylum
seeking pharmaceutical salesman and i
resent the way you did it but the
child thing is not funny it's
heartbreaking and you need to work
backwards from that moment right how did
he as
as people were saying how did he get
here why did he get here
who did this there are multiple villains
here there are the coyotes who desert
them
and they're the hyenas in our government
uh who've gone on for years egging on
this
this thing because and the bottom line
is
is that they don't see this as a problem
when when there's when they see stuff
like this they just consider that
childhood
an egg that you break to make an omelet
because this is going to evolve towards
a certain kind of uh border
uh transformation that will appeal to
the people that want amnesty
this is just part of the part of the
thing to break you know it
it's kind of sad it's just sad because
no one actually really cares
and so juan why have we not seen you
know
any more sort of like visible action and
i am curious
about kamala harris i don't expect her
to solve this overnight but
she was given this assignment and aside
from a couple of phone calls there's
really been nothing what's that about
i don't think there's been nothing dana
i think that she is involved in the
outreach to
not only mexico you mentioned the call
with the president of mexico today
but also guatemala honduras uh an
attempt to understand how we can
intervene
you know this is a point that you've
raised previously to
stop the flow from those countries to
give people a reason to stay
i just wanted to say that you know that
picture that you showed just tore me
apart i just you know it's just
that's a that's a child and he's lost
and he's abandoned
and and to me this is in keeping with
the idea that we've seen
for generations in terms of immigrants
who want to come to america
it's a human tragedy it's a human story
that child's
not a gang banger he's not ms-13 he's
not a terrorist he's not a drug dealer
he's a child and he's representative of
desperate
poor hungry people who are fleeing
violence in their home countries that's
why people take that
risk that's why you would put your own
flesh and blood
in that dangerous position they want a
better life and
you know as americans we know this story
this is america's story
the story of immigration is america's
story and
you know to suddenly make that child
into the depiction of oh that's a
bad kid or that's a gang or that's you
know it's just not
us and that's when you hear president
biden talk about american values we're
not sending that kid
back into the desert i mean i think that
is
who we are we're we're not thinking
nobody called him a gang member nobody
called him a gang member
you're hearing things again no one's
been anything but heartbroken for that
child kennedy
and presumably the parents in mexico
assume that
or he's from nicaragua maybe they
presume that
they might be also able to join him if
he's able to get across and eventually
they might be able to join them that's
but that's the incentive and that's the
problem with this administration
is they are not creating clear systems
for people to come here legally exactly
and and we we do have to uh and
by the way kamala harris was united
states senator she knows how congress
works
so she should lay out a plan of action
so
congress has something where they can
immediately start passing
legislation for short-term and long-term
immigration problems
this short-term problem is incredibly
heartbreaking think about what this kid
has gone through juan
he's got instability in his home country
his parents have probably sold
everything
uh to get him to the united states they
have no possessions
we're in the middle of a global pandemic
and and that has terrified children
in every country in every part of the
world and then
he makes that journey from nicaragua
finally makes it to the united states
and he is completely abandoned there and
imagine how this this child has been
traumatized
that is not how a caring humane country
does immigration right and when you have
a vice president who's the point person
on this
who has gone completely awol it sends a
message
that she doesn't care she doesn't care
about this child
and one i don't think of this child as a
gang member i don't think this child is
guilty of anything
i i agree i share your vision of how
immigration has made this country
a better place but my biggest concern
is the kids who don't make it this kid
made it to the united states and found a
cbp officer
we have no way of knowing how many
children have died
along the way and that's what we should
be caring about
and the trauma that they've suffered i
just want to agree with you kennedy
i just want to say i agree with you
kenny i wish that the congress
you know we discussed this on the show
earlier which congress would stop doing
the photo
ops and and the finger pointing and get
something done maybe harry should be did
you think
that did you think that when the
democrats went to the border
yeah and had aoc weeping iva i said this
i said this in 2013 when there was a
deal i said it in 17 when trump
was trying to make a deal uh i think it
was with dick durbin
let's get a deal done on immigration
reform
in the meantime we have to also have
policies that will stop the current
search because the legislation will be a
while
all right ahead